[Music]
[Applause]
what what you want Ruby I was thinking
Ruby might have come back into heat this
morning but she's not showing any signs
now so I guess not she stopped at the
buck pan I thought hmm did we not get
your bread last dad so I think we have a
ton of goats bread starting Valentine's
Day on we should have some babies
dropping so what about you autumn you're
a teen aren't you
we're not gonna breed autumn we're not
gonna do that to her
her little sweetness we just don't want
to we just don't want to she's too sweet
I don't want to mess up any of her
awesome body condition because she looks
so healthy now so I guess she's always
been a little plump girl like her mama
where's-where's time that's hearts
hearts is looking pretty plump too so I
think we bred hearts
I think fern may have had a go fancy
girl Mamie shy
Dominique time kitty fancy too shady I
think that's it
oh and truly I'm pretty sure she's bred
but time right here right and I've been
talking about how she is like the
easiest keeper and the whole herd she
never has issues and she's always got a
thick shiny coat and she's always got a
nice plump body and she stays and milk
for a long time she's still in milk and
it's been a year since autumn was born
so it is tempting to grate on them my
dad thinks I should he thinks it would
be good for her spiritually that she
would enjoy being a mom but sorry to add
I'm just not ready yet maybe next year I
just feel like anytime you breathe in
animal
you gotta be prayer for any type of
pregnancy complications birthing
complications that could potentially
harm them and I'm just not not prepared
for that with my sweet autumn so we'll
breed her again and hopefully get
another beautiful autumn that that won't
end up with the deficiency that harmed
her so much while she was developing so
look at them goofy that kids eat goats
love my goats
oh poor fluff another no girlfriend
today oh you are disgusting
poor fluffer nutters getting no pets
from mommy if you guys remember the
first two years that we had him in the
fall he never really went into rut like
he never did the whole stinky buck thing
look at his face that is so stinky his
ears are white normally his chest is
whitening his beard is white he's
disgusting he's so gross in the stench
is so foul and I'm not pretty okay with
a goat buck smell but he's gross
well Peter pepper is not as stinky
that's the old water by the way the new
waters in there I got up I'm just gonna
dump that on the grounding rod you stink
ooh boy I can't wait until rut season is
over and I could pet you again yeah he's
been getting rough with Peter not too
bad just an occasional random RAM he's
still a sweet boy
Oh gross II stinky it quit spraying up
your nostrils that's gross I guess one
of the benefits of having a drought in
the middle of the summer in Georgia is
that finally we're having a break from
major parasite loads the spring weather
that was so wet after the winter that
had no cold weather to kill off
parasites was very rough on us when we
went into the spring and into the
beginning of the summer we had serious
parasite issues in our herd we had a lot
of
problems and it was very scary and we
had some losses and it was very
difficult that all happened during the
time when I wasn't making videos I
wasn't I wasn't doing well with it
mentally or physically with my health so
it became really hard for me to pick up
the camera so just know that every time
you get a video from me that it's just a
sign of me feeling better and I'm
definitely feeling a lot better mentally
physically I think once the 90 degree
weather cools off I think I'll be
feeling a lot better
the quail are doing great they just went
through a molt so their egg-laying
slowed down a little bit but not nearly
as much as when a chicken molt's it
seems like it's a faster process for
them so we've been supplementing with
mealworms from our meal worm colony if
you're interested in that I'll leave a
link to our video showing the easy way
to grow mealworms without having all the
extra steps of separating out the
different stages the mealworms provide
extra protein to help with the new
feather growth we also make sure that we
continue giving them the high-protein
game bird feed that's really important
to their health and keeping them
actively laying and doing well
[Music]
I have to give another huge thank you to
the people who came out for the whole
submergence summer soirée for all of
their help in the weeding of this garden
I am so happy to say that these
asparagus have been regrowing through
this drought and heat because of the
weed suppression being taken off of them
so it looks like we're gonna have a
great asparagus harvest in the spring
because the plants are coming back into
their healthy strong health it's funny
because in New England and other cooler
parts of the country people say that
asparagus grows wild on the side of the
road in in the ditches with the weeds
but here in Georgia the slightest amount
of weed stress well not the slightest it
does okay with chicory there's a winter
cover crop but when it gets that
creeping Charlie in there and the
goldenrod that was growing up in it it
really stressed the plants out and made
them not produce as much so it's
interesting to me that it doesn't do as
well in the south as it does the north
obviously but that the weeds make a big
difference so we're gonna have to really
stay on top of it this year and once the
winter kills back all of the screen
fern foliage on the asparagus we're
gonna go through and put a nice thick
layer of mulch to protect it from the
weeds in the spring our permaculture
perennial fruit and berry bed kind of
got a hit to it the goats got out
somehow they knocked down one of the
posts probably because it's so dry out
it loosened up in the ground and I
looked out here and they were Mallen
down
they ate down all the leaves off of the
raspberries but you can see they're
regrowing from the center so they're
coming back but they ate down all of
those they down all the comfrey they ate
down all the strawberries so the
strawberries already going back here let
me show you one down here where it's
like real obvious like this you see
these sticks
we're all leaves those were all leaves
growing and so when the goats ate them
off the strawberry started producing new
leaves down at the base from the center
rosette so it's really bouncing back
quite well and I think it's gonna be
fine
we'll still have plenty of strawberry in
the spring of course all it's a tomato a
dead dead dead did the basil went to
seed
it's beautiful still I think but it's
dropping its seed left and right I need
to harvest some of these seed heads so
that I can grow more next year this was
a lemon basil I got from Kaylee at the
honey said this little volunteer tiny
cherry tomato it's probably a current or
wild Tom one of those types it's still
producing fruit despite the fact that
all the other have died the peppers that
we're producing at the beginning of the
season are dying back probably a lot to
do with the drought plus it looks like
the goats got to it the pepino melons
never did produce fruit so I don't know
if it's because of the drought or we
didn't have a long enough growing season
I'll definitely try planting them again
because they showed a lot of potential
um these tomato plants have a lot of
herbicide curl on them so they haven't
ever produced anything really worth
speaking my Roselle got knocked over and
nibbled on by the goats but it is still
producing huge huge buds so we're gonna
be harvesting these pretty soon I don't
want to do a video on that so hopefully
I'll take you along and you can see what
we do with these usually they're
standing upright like okra but they fell
over
peppers on this end are doing a great
job steal these purple peppers were the
first peppers to produce and they I
think are going to be the last ones to
produce they seem to me to do really
well through all temperatures of the
season this right here is one of the
ones that I was really excited about
trying this year I got these seeds from
Jess at roots and refuge and this is
arroz con pollo and it took forever to
start producing blooms so now it's
starting to bloom and some fruit is
developing so we will definitely get to
try it
my goes kind of surprised me because
they came over here and ate all the
horseradish leaf down so I wasn't
expecting them to be interested in that
but it's okay the plant is regrowing
leaves just like everything else
goldenrod is just taking off over here
all of the plants kind of fell over but
they are blooming like crazy and feeding
the honeybees and all the other bees and
pollinators unfortunately our main stand
that we had from that water tank down
got cut down during the soiree so we
don't have as much as we used to on this
side of the garden but we still have
some and it does spread quite easily so
we'll be fine and just over the garden
fence over here by the pond you can see
how much the drought has affected us the
water line usually comes up to about
where that sedges and the edge of the
water would be here their water line
went down so far early in the season
that plants were able to grow all the
way out to there and then it got even
worse and the water line has receded
even more so our pond is the lowest it's
ever been since we've lived here but we
still have water so it's ok we still are
feeding our wildlife and taking care of
the environment by allowing plants to
grow around the edges of the pond that
are
official to pollinators in other
wildlife we're doing our part to keep
the world a little healthier the good
news is the forecast is calling for
cooling temperatures this weekend and
next week so that means we're gonna get
out of the 90s to us that's cooling
temperatures a lot of people in the
country are dealing with snow and
freezing already and we are over here
going it is 95 degrees it feels like 100
not fun but thankfully it looks like
it's going to get into the 80s and
possibly even 70s
next week with a chance of rain on
Monday or Tuesday so if that happens um
these beds are gonna be sown so quickly
with my carrots beets collards kale and
we will have a fall crop and I'm really
grateful for all the help getting this
ready for fall garden and I'm really
glad that I didn't rush to get it
planted that week because it all would
have died all of my friends that live in
the area have all been posting sad sad
stories and pictures of what's happened
to their fall crops and let me tell you
it's not pretty
so we got lucky that we didn't do it
when we should have as a normal season
ghost because this season has been
nothing close to normal all right
speaking of hot it is getting hot out
here I'm gonna go inside if you haven't
checked out our amazon links down below
you know a while please do Amazon
affiliate associates do rely on a slight
Commission being earned every month or
they will cancel it due to the fact that
I haven't been producing videos very
often our Amazon sales have declined all
you gotta do is use the link it doesn't
charge you any extra it's the same cost
to you it just gives us a tiny
Commission off of each of the sales used
in our link so it's very appreciated if
you do so if you do shop on Amazon it's
a great way
to help support the channel and our
family for those of you that have
continued to use the Amazon link I
really appreciate it it has kept us
being able to keep an active status so
hopefully we'll see an increase here as
we start producing more videos thank you
guys for all of your support
[Music]
you